I could not help but as I was collecting
my thoughts this morning
about how I might introduce the subject
and introduce Patrick and I was very
struck by the front page article in The
Washington Post violence turnover blunt
CIA effort in Iraq and of course it's
the old story of an intelligence agency
of people serving with its Special
Forces and others are being thrown into
a situation where they're greatly
outnumbered where no one's quite clear
on what the objectives are but do it
anyway and where they are putting their
lives on the line for their country and
I thought what a what a matching
successor to OSS the CI has been
certainly in these last few years and
and I having served in CI for some 36
years take great pride in that and take
great pride in being related in some way
to so many of you who served in OSS I
think one thing that I also thought was
what is it about us as what is it about
people who go into Special Forces what
is it that causes people to go into
things like underwater demolition Tim's
teams and so forth and I happen to
glance up at my my bookcase and there's
this Nathan Hale statue that sold out at
the agency occasionally I regret that I
have one life to lose for my country I
don't know if you knew it but one of
your colleagues Bill Casey also an OSS
veteran didn't care for the Nathan he
was he wasn't sure we should be selling
it because he said first of all it was
an operation against the British
secondly had failed so anyway they sell
it anyway
but it is the model in some ways of
someone in his case a rank amateur with
virtually no training who readily
grasped a mission for his country sought
to do it and of course lost his life in
the process but emerged of course as a
hero for us as a country and very much
for those of us who have followed in
that path the I think that passion and
that dedication of country is so so
clear in things like the OSS Special
Forces and related services because the
near certainty of what will happen to
them if they are caught is
characteristic the fact that they are
often sent out to places where they are
essentially alone it is a very lonely
job at times the intelligence job
because no matter what the teamwork back
at headquarters no matter how many
briefings you've had how many
simulations you've run through in the
end
it's often you by yourself perhaps with
a handful of people you've never met who
are foreign and you are foreign in a
foreign country and I think those
characteristics
I think the agencies that have been
successors to OSS have held up that that
banner the I noticed one of the comments
in that article was by Jim pavatt who's
head of the clandestine service the
direct successor to all of those who
were operational who said there is no
shortage of volunteers for Iraq so I
think that that speaks eloquently to
what I am talking about so let me get to
today's author Patrick O'Donnell his
book operative spies saboteurs Patrick
is very much and I'm delighted to say
this in the tradition of this museum the
museum is story driven the people who
come here hear many stories about people
who have spied for and against their
country and the idea of course is to
give them a sense of what intelligence
is about what espionage is about the
price that people have to pay from time
to time to engage in those activities
and the incredible consequences it can
have on history and so by telling it
through stories which you have done
Patrick I think is to catch the wind to
catch people's interest I am so moved by
the young people who go through here
they don't take in everything they're
not label readers but they take in the
stories and if they are stimulated by
the stories to go back and learn a
little more about the Civil War the
Revolutionary War or OSS and World War
two then we've done our job then we're a
success and I think that's why your book
will do well Patrick that you have done
Patrick as an expert historian as you
know on World War two and special
operations particularly OSS and Special
Operations it's my understanding he did
something over 1400 interviews to
produce this book as well as I
understand you were also a consultant on
band of brothers which was the
miniseries Patrick I should say by the
way was a recipient of the William E
Colby Award for military history he has
consulted on Band of Brothers and has
consulted on other BBC Fox News and The
History Channel and he has created an
award-winning website called the drop
zone which is the first online oral
history for veterans of world war ii and
the interested public how timely that we
are so close to the dedication of the
world war ii memorial so patrick thank
you for helping OSS to tell its stories
they will endure
I think you've performed a real service
here we welcome you to the museum
thank you party tonight yeah there you
are okay I just want to thank everybody
here especially all the veterans that
are here this is what it's all about
you and your stories I conducted most of
my research at the National Archives and
while I was there I ran into a fellow
researcher slash historian and he said
to me he's also doing a book on
intelligence history that the OSS never
did anything significant during World
War two and I said why don't you have a
seat and we'll talk about that he's like
alright I'm interested here what you say
and I ran down a list in North Africa
for instance OSS pioneered the
intelligence efforts there making it a
successful invasion OSS at Anzio one
single spy along with a network of spies
helped determine when the next invasion
was going to take place the next German
attack before ultra the enemy objectives
unit is something called which pioneered
strategic bombing analysis was OSS
driven it determined which choke points
were in Europe and we targeted certain
oil refineries as well as ball bearing
plants special ops were created by OSS
Corsica and Sardinia were taken by so
one or two man teams an OSS were 275,000
Italians surrendered to a small team led
by Sergio Belinsky OSS double agents
deceived German the German High Command
during the Battle of the Bulge letting
them think that Patton's advance was
coming piecemeal and then several days
behind schedule one agent Mali was able
to convince the Hungarian government to
turn sides OSS organized partisans in
Italy where over 200,000 partisans
helped create a fourth arm in the last
allied a major offensive during the war
operation sunrise was was crucial in
creating the German forces in Italy to
surrender one week before the rest of
German forces it could have even been
more successful had the Russians not
gotten involved in the invasion of
southern France 50% or more of the
intelligence was gathered by OSS but
this is not what the book is about it's
about the people that are behind those
operations it's about the men and women
that are in the front row of this room
as well as around the country who gave
me their stories I'd like to take a
quote from one of people that I that
that's in the book a violent blow broke
two of my teeth and I was once again
kicked to the ground my mouth was full
of blood and I was in pain I was made to
lie down on a bench while one man took
hold of a pickaxe which was lying around
for three hours they held me there
well I endured the most violent lashing
with this instrument one will cut my
scalp open and I was to drench with
blood I thought that they were going to
kill me and I waited for a moment saying
to myself they could do anything they
want but they're not going to force me
to talk Arno knew nothing he was beaten
as hard as I was regardless of his age
but one word escaped his lips not one
word escaped his lips we were placed
against the wall and threatened with
being shot at which time we decided that
if we were going to die we would die
with courage this is about courage and
bravery of all the people in this room
and that were in OSS Lance the person
that that told that story went to Dachau
for over a year he helped build the camp
they survived the war so many agents
were either killed or captured during
World War two and that's that's kind of
what this book is all about it's about
courage and sacrifice and bravery of
these individuals that are probably the
most remarkable people that I've ever
interviewed for me this project began in
1992 I graduated from college and over
the summer I was
at the Aberdeen Proving Grounds and I
ran into a veteran from the 82nd
Airborne Division and he started to tell
me his story it's the same unit that my
uncle was part of and I'd been
interested in world war two since I was
five or six but my relatives never told
me their stories when I asked them they
would always say well it was really
difficult experience and I really can't
get into it but this man started to tell
me a story
and it was the beginning of an
incredible journey for me I've
interviewed over 1400 War two veterans
over the past twelve years from the
elite units in particular and then OSS
as well as other espionage units and my
the first thing that began was something
called the drop zone org which was the
first online oral history project on the
web and it just kind of blossomed from
there in the veterans themselves were
the ones that said to me why don't you
tell our story and do it and write a
book and I wrote beyond valor and
subsequently into the Rising Sun and I
was now operative spies and saboteurs so
it was from the veterans themselves that
that I was able to I got my inspiration
basically and that's really what it's
all about let's talk about the OSS for a
minute the OSS why it was established it
before World War two America had an
aversion to spy craft gentlemen didn't
open other gentleman's mail in many
cases and it was even worse in terms of
the few intelligence agencies that we
did have at the time Oh ñi Office of
Naval Intelligence g2 which was Army
Intelligence and then the State
Department which had diplomats actually
gathering intelligence
nobody was coordinating any of this
information so the the president tried
to create something and it didn't go
very far the the then British intervened
and said you know you really need to get
get moving on this and the coordinator
of information was formed in 1941 a year
later
OSs it went through a name change in OSS
was created it was the inspiration
though of general Donovan that was a
driving force behind OSS and his
personality and spirit he's one of the
most remarkable individuals this country
ever had a true great hero
Donovan didn't just sit behind a desk as
the book will show he was in he and pea
landed in nearly every major invasion
including Normandy on the first day
Sicily Salerno went to Burma he was very
active he wouldn't do anything that he
wouldn't want his spies that his spies
wouldn't do and he created this amazing
organization probably I think one of the
greatest organizations overnight that
this America this country has ever had
but you know after the war there was a
group of people that studied the OSS and
they said basically it undertook and
carried out more different types of
enterprises calling upon more varied
skills than any other single
organization of its size in the history
of this country I think that's a troops
true quote OSS is probably the most
dynamic and interesting organization
that's created this country has ever
created overnight we built a spy
organization we've built Special Forces
we combine that with psychological
operations we had a research and
analysis division all within one under
one roof which was unique compared to
the British intelligence services of its
time which were siloed or stove-piped
it's the people that made up the
organization that that made it so
dynamic though you had not only Ivy
League professors analyzing information
but you had in cases where you needed to
crack open a safe a person was sprung
out of prison or you had the
paratroopers that were brought out of
parachute units to act as OSS as
commandos just the most incredible
people you could ever imagine there are
ordinary people though that became
citizen spies that did extraordinary
things as this book will show
I'd like to talk a little bit about the
training that OSS went through which is
really pretty interesting they wanted to
assess the skill capabilities of the
people that they had and they had
several mental tests that they put
people through and as the war went on
for instance one test that always kind
of cracks me up was the Buster and Kippy
test and spies were told that they had
to build a tinker toy house and Buster
and kemppi were there to aid them it
turned out that that Buster and Kippy
didn't follow orders that well and
whenever you gave Kippy an order he
would just say well I don't know how to
do that or and then the other guy would
say well here's how you do and you try
to direct it the whole thing turned into
a Three Stooges comedy scene and the
only way that Buster and Kippy ever
built the house was by a large Texan who
flattened Buster and Kippy and they
built the house himself your typical OSS
style ha ha ha I think that's the key
here is people people in the OSS were
out of box out-of-the-box thinkers they
did things they were creative and that
carried through not only in World War
two but also after the war another
people another story that every veteran
in the room will talk about or the
person they'll talk about most most will
I should say is the hand-to-hand combat
training that they received in OSS and
most most of the OSS training schools
were actually right here in the
Washington area like the Congressional
Country Club for instance and then Camp
David was also turned into a training
training facility but the the one person
that always comes to mind is Maj
Fairburn and Maj Fairburn is a
remarkable guy he was known as the
Shanghai Buster because in the 1920s he
was in charge of the police force there
and had gotten in at the time he'd
gotten into over 2,000 street fights
became a master in jujitsu and
hand-to-hand combat and most of the
people in the room can have a story
about major Fairburn that that's
interesting for instance ed wise Miller
over here is who was a part of the
x---two branch can show you how to take
it
Norden airily
ordinary newspaper and turned into a
deadly stiletto unfortunately and I had
the the chance for him to do that and it
works okay it didn't work that well but
the talking about out-of-the-box type
thinking and characteristics the other
person I'd like to introduce is Charles
Parkin jr. and he was one of OSS his
main demolition men and just an expert
on demolition and he got into the OSS by
some of you may have even gone up i-95
to this this this meeting today the
railroad bridge right next to i-95 was
kind of the scene of where he got into
the coordinator of information then or
OSS the he as he was coming back from
maneuvers he noticed that the bridge was
lightly guarded by one or two men and he
thought he knew right away that that
bridge could easily be sabotaged if it
wasn't guarded properly so he took in
his own initiative he got his assault
engineer assault unit together they
wrote into boats and they rigged up the
bridge with false demolition charges and
then they went the next day they went
and they said look what can happen if
the bridge isn't properly guarded and
they were shocked of course and I said
why we've got a place for you it's
called the OSS and he became one of OSS
master demolitionists he was later
joined by his fraternity mate Frank
Gleason who's here today and one of the
great saboteurs and demolitionists
during world war ii his specialty he got
his training from the SOE over in
England learned how to take down a city
with three or four men which is pretty
scary if you think about it taking out a
power plant telephone exchange whatever
perhaps my favorite story though with
Frank is something called Aunt Jemima
an Aunt Jemima is a flower like
substance that's kind of gritty though
but it's actually plastic explosives and
it could be turned into an ordinary loaf
of
or muffins can be turned into a hand
grenade and Frank wanted to demonstrate
the the capabilities of this substance
to major miles who is at a time part of
the off the Navy's Intelligence Group in
China and they they had a Chinese cook
bake up several muffins with Aunt Jemima
and the he warned the cook do not eat
the muffins are dangerous whatever you
do do not eat the muffins
well the cook thought that he was
getting screwed out of a few muffins and
decided to eat the muffins and was
doubled over for about six months after
that but uh anyways the this stuff is
pretty amazing the not only the people
but things that were developed by OSS
are also pretty impressive I'm now going
to step through kind of the basic
structure of OSS and how it fits into
the people in this room the first
organization I'd like branch I'd like to
talked about in OSS is Secret
Intelligence and Secret Intelligence is
the agent stuff it's secret agents going
behind the lines in civilian clothes
it's gathering human intelligence about
key key installations and operations
it's also a place where a single
individual or a small team of people can
make a huge difference and the
individual that I'd like to highlight is
in this room
his name is Fred Mayer and he's one of
the most remarkable people I've ever
interviewed
Fred was born in Germany in 1938 he left
Germany was he was forced to flee
Germany along with the rest of his
family he went to New York City and
during the time of the war he
volunteered and was in a ranger unit and
he at the time he he committed he
captured a command post single-handedly
and they said we have a place for you
it's called OSS and Fred was put into
the German og group and the OGIS are a
were OSS commandos and they were 30 man
teams typically that dropped
on the line in uniform but at the OGIS
at the time the German oh jeez never
were activated because they didn't have
a mission in Germany so Fred asked to be
transferred to the Secret Intelligence
Unit and he had one of the most amazing
stories the war he was he along with two
other men one who was a German prisoner
of war dropped outside of Innsbruck
Austria on the side of a glacier they
they found a small sled and they were
able to sled down the side of the
glacier then they they were on a they
made their way to a train station and
they they boarded a train as they they
were on the train they were they were
still in American uniforms below white
ski capes
so they look like Alpine troops but they
still had American uniforms on
underneath them and the true enough as
they were on the train the train was
being searched by the conductor who
wanted the tickets and the the man in
the group that was a prisoner of war
said we're on a ski but we're on a ski
patrol were two South Pine troops and
the conductor said okay fine next person
came by was the Gestapo and the Gestapo
said show me your passes and ha the the
German prisoner of war said we've
already been checked and they said
remarkably they passed on they passed
the team by and it's it's the beginning
of one of the great stories in OSS where
a single team or sing in a single person
can really make a huge difference he
then was taken to the hospital where the
sister of the powa
and was given a false head wound
dressing and he assumed the name of
lieutenant Frederick Mayer Vera mock and
was in the basically in the hospital
recovering from his wounds where he
started to listen to people that were
around him and he would go to the
officers mess in the hospital and listen
to stories one of the first stories he
found out about is a German engineer
that worked on the Fuehrer bunker was
able to find the exact dimensions
the Fuehrer bunker if anybody's
questioning the validity to this story
all they have to do is go to the
National Archives and find they'll find
that that Fred radiates Fred Mayer's
radio transcripts are there detailing
everything that I say by the way as well
as it is corroborated by his teammates
after you receive that he decided to
take a stroll down to the local rail
yard and talk to the rail master who
said who in passing said to him that
there were 26 trains that were headed
for Italy fully loaded with tanks and
artillery
Fred Mayer called in those that that
those trains and they called in an
airstrike and destroyed all 26 trains as
one aide to Eisenhower said they may
have shortened the war by six months in
that theater the he then assumed the OSS
wanted intelligence on German jet
production so he became a French
electrician that was coming from the
east and worked in the measure Schmidt
plant in the area but found out that
there were no spare parts so plane
production wasn't going anywhere what
happened next was there was a knock on
the door and it was the Gestapo who
found found Fred and then they they
interrogated him for three days they
hung him upside down they beat him
poured water on his ears dunked him
underwater that then he turned the
tables on his captors who believed that
he was a high-ranking OSS official who
could do who could take care of their
war crimes if they did the right thing
and from there he was able to convince
them that the to let it let him free and
also to surrender the city of Innsbruck
Austria to the advancing hundred fourth
Division this is a completely true story
and Frederick mayor presented the city
of Innsbruck to the advancing hundred
fourth Division
sure I can tell the story better
I'm sure Fred can tell the story better
than I can but that's that the heart of
it and it's it's remarkable but it's
like so many people in this room another
person in the room is Jacques Schneider
who who was part of Secret Intelligence
he initially was part of s oh he dropped
into France to set up a an intelligence
network Rossano which is the French
Network term for it and was extremely
successful at doing that they created
several ambushes but they were also
ambushed by the FTP which is the
communist arm of the French Resistance
who were vying for their supplies as
well as trying to kill them and it was
really kind of a chilling first chapter
of the Cold War that Jacques was in I'm
going to move now on to the OGS and
they're fascinating group there they're
a subsection actually of special
operations within OSS but the OGS were
OSS is commandos and I don't think
there's one story that really highlights
this better than any other story the OGS
were thirty fifteen to thirty man teams
that drop behind the lines in uniform to
sabotage tunnels blow up bridges
organize the resistance arm the
resistance and in some cases actually
fight pitch battles and the one the
story that comes to mind here is
something called is team Louise and team
Louise was in southern France their main
mission was to drop a large bridge on
the Rhone River and also halt the German
verbs stem the German advance north
on August 25th they they basically they
had to 37 millimeter guns and were
peppering the Germans around a small
town the the French Resistance kind of
most of the French resistance fighters
had left the area they didn't realize
this at the time but a German captain
came up to part of the Patrol as it was
getting as team Louise was getting hit
pretty bad by German small fire small
arms fire and said asked his potentially
to surrender and they said okay said
okay fine why don't you try to get the
rest of your team to surrender so he
went back and they never heard from this
guy again but they used a a white flag
to see if anybody else would surrender
they went up to they were approached by
two Colonels two German Colonels who
said we're not going to surrender we
have you know several thousand troops
here you're it but team Louise said to
them basically they were getting strafe
by the air and they were also being
surrounded by these guns and some French
resistance fighters you're completely
surrounded you should give up and the
colonel said please you're our prisoners
and we're not you know we're not
surrendering we're going to keep you and
they basically said to him we're
expendable and if you don't meet this
deadline within a few within an hour the
rest of the forces are going to
overwhelm you
the Germans spot the bluff and thirty
eight hundred Germans were captured that
day by five commanders so I mean anybody
that doesn't that can't that doesn't
think that OSS made a difference during
World War two I think they need to ask
some of the people that are here or look
at this and look at their stories and
also their record which speaks for
itself
the OGIS were extremely active
throughout europe and uh
another another another unit or branch
they like to talk about is special
operations which actually do cheese were
part of and I already introduced Frank
Gleason who was a master demolitionist
in China Frank had to stem he had to
basically stem the Japanese advance the
Japanese in 1944 wanted to attack our
airfield so we had b-29s in China so
they made a large push in China to take
those airfields back and Frank as well
as well as Charlie Parkin were there
destroying bridges as fast as they could
to stem this Japanese advance they blew
up over 150 bridges culverts dams
anything they could to block the
Japanese advance as well as munitions
warehouses Frank later blew up the
Yellow River bridge in China with
another team and had to spent three days
avoiding Japanese patrols another
individual that's here is general jack
singh lob who's a linked living legend
he was part of the Jedburgh teams in
France these are three-man teams that
were they tried to make them up along
multinational lines French English and
American didn't always work out that way
but his team was pretty much aligned
during the along those lines and he
operated in France but I had a chance to
interview him on a mercy mission that he
was involved in on Hainan Island where
he dropped in and helped preserve the
lives of several thousand Allied
prisoners of war from being killed by
the Japanese the the next branch that
I'd like to talk about is
counterintelligence
it's got a sexy name it's called x2 in
counterintelligence is is basically
dealing with
doubling it enemy agents and trying to
counter the intelligence services of
other of other intelligence agencies
person that's here is really pretty
remarkable individual his name is Edward
wise Miller and he handled the first
controlled enemy agent in France the the
agents code name was draaga mon and it's
Ed's story is pretty remarkable he he
you had to think one step ahead of the
Germans constantly every they were there
basically after the agent was controlled
they had to feed the agent fit false
informations that the Germans then took
that they believed was true and the
information was partially true but
generally mostly false and it was all
part of a deception operation that that
OSS was was engaged in at the time as
the war went on the the agent was so
trusted that they considered him one of
their best agents the Germans did and he
as a unit was later involved in feeding
it deception information on the Allied
invasion of the Rhine among other things
the next unit I'd like to talk about is
really kind of one of OSS greatest
untold stories I think it's called Moran
the maritime unit or a special boat
which included transport units for boats
as well as frogmen and basically their
boat handlers would take out agents and
drop them off and they'd also drop off
supplies but there were also frogman
units within the EMU units they were
they're called combat swimmers and
gentlemen here today is John booth he
was one of OSS his first frogmen he was
involved in an operation at Guantanamo
Bay where we went in under under cover
of darkness underwater and basically
went underneath the torpedo nets
and blew up several barges in front of
you no American troops it was part of an
exercise to demonstrate the
effectiveness of of combat swimmers he
later worked in Burma and did
reconnaissance work on entitled in the
Andes small River inlets called tidal
qiong's and his the person that
transported him around quite a bit
is Walter mess and he's probably here
also
mr. mess was responsible for for driving
a lot of the special operations or
frogman units around in Burma the next
unit or branch that I'd like to talk to
talk about is morale operations and this
is black propaganda and spreading rumors
disinformation dirty tricks the woman
here today is a remarkable lady barber
Podolski she's 90 years old today and
just just a remarkable woman she was
involved in something called Operation
sauerkraut where German prisoners of war
were taken back she had to interview
them and they were then given propaganda
leaflets and then sent back behind
German lines to spread disinformation in
rumors it was extremely the operation
sauerkraut was extremely effective and
even Field Marshal Kesselring had to
deny many of the rumors that sauerkraut
was spreading but I think my most my
most interesting anecdote that I have
about mrs. Podolski is her interaction
with some of these German prisoners of
war she's absolutely a fearless lady she
she had to interrogate a six-foot-two SS
officer and the officer basically
started defaming America and also called
President Roosevelt a Jew at which point
she hauled off and gave him a knuckle
sandwich
the officer was so stunned that he
didn't know what to do when he asked
that she'd be removed from the tent but
of course it did happen but he quickly
shut up also but it's it's this is the
kind of people that are in this book
it's just remarkable people that have
done you know extraordinary things you
know ordinary ordinary Americans that
came to the call of duty to do
extraordinary things for this country
and really it's it's the building blocks
for for the CIA the the war on terror
right now so much of what it what's
going on stems from OSS at that point I
happy to take questions
I traveled all around the country it was
it I actually interviewed 1,400 people
for for all three of the books that I
wrote into the Rising Sun beyond valor
not precise the saboteurs but I traveled
all around the country to reunions to
people's homes you know in some cases
neutral ground where people didn't want
I had to meet at a few McDonald's and
you know but it worked out it was in it
for me this that was the best part of
the the whole process it was meeting
extraordinary people and learning their
their stories about life as well as um
you know the the inspiration behind the
stories and also learning something
about myself and it was it was a
remarkable process it's the best part of
this is my passion it's not a work thing
at all I I really enjoy it the thing
that I enjoy the most is it is meeting
the people that are in this room and
around the country that I've talked to
yeah
yeah I'm wondering um actually of
obviously owner superb on organization
why was it disbanded after the war and
don't you think it would have been good
here to keep it um especially in view of
the fact that you know few years later
you have the CIA absolutely it was
mistakes I think that President Truman
made and September 30th 1945 OSS was
disbanded largely for political reasons
I think there is also some infiltration
by communist agents within OSS which was
problematic but the reality is just as
the gentleman said OSS was refloated as
CIA two years later it was almost it was
basically the underpinnings of OSS and a
lot of the people from OSS just went
over to CIA
and it was a mistake I think to have a
gap and you know our intelligence
capabilities for those two years
especially since we had to just be able
to tear the whole thing down and and
then recreate it with CIA
it's a friend infiltration okay you
might be interested to know that when
we're in the mountains of Maryland we
trained a whole group of people from the
Lincoln Brigade and these people had
been timing this who fought against in
Spain and they were being trained they
were being trained by OSS to go be
infiltrated back into Spain you know
because we thought the Germans were
going to come in there and take over
Spain one that's absolutely true and
it's it kind of shows a diversity of
people that were recruited by Bill
Donovan into the OSS in fact one of the
individuals in the end of that story of
that group is in the book his name is
Milton Felsen and Felson served as a
machine gunner in the spanish-american
war and was part of the Abraham Lincoln
Brigade and fought extremely
courageously in North Africa but at the
time it's one of the things that
happened with with OSS people didn't
understand how to utilize OSS special
operatives for instance and they they
took elsens team along with another guy
by the name of Jerry sage who Frank
knows pretty well or knew I should say
and they said ok we want you to destroy
Panzers with Molotov cocktails and this
is at castle rain pass where you know
we're being overwhelmed by by tanks and
everything else and then subsequently
Felson and the team were captured by the
Germans and spent the rest of the war in
German prisoner of war camps he later
then became the producer for pretty
well-known film called Saturday Night
Fever yeah
thank you the poor are pleased to
service the grassroots coalition working
the homeland security initiative of Tom
Ridgeway thank you very much
well my books about heroes and they're
in this room and I think there's a lot
that we can all learn from
I should have there's been a there's a
security breach here and of course
you're all familiar with that term
and that is that I did not let you know
that c-span would be joining us today
therefore those of you in OSS who have
maintained your cover but it is now now
probably going to be blown my
understanding is that this today's
program will be shown on c-span on
booknotes which is typically aired on
Sunday we're not absolutely positive of
that don't know which Sunday but if you
are interested and want to keep in touch
with our office with either Amanda olcay
or our media Reverend Amanda our Braille
will be glad to to get back to you and
let you know all of the folks who work
on these programs are made are named
Amanda and that's so they'll be you know
that's of a cover name that we use for
this okay
I I should have mentioned to you that
flash flash would have been fine just as
long as you weren't too distracting
anybody I did want to mention to you
that we will be doing another program
with Patrick and that's tales from the
OSS America's first intelligence agency
on Thursday 27 May and that'll be an
evening program at 7:00 p.m. there are
Flyers on this and where are they backed
by the book okay um if you have specific
feedback on the program if you have
suggestions for other programs I really
we depend a lot on feedback the person
who has organized this meeting Carol
miner who is a CIA veteran is sitting
right back here or either of the Amanda
cover name folks would be glad to
your suggestion so but we do encourage
you to get back to us so I would I say
that will involve Patrick and I believe
Jack general Singh lob you're involved
as well that correct and I think
Elizabeth Macintosh also okay so that
should be an absolutely sorry and Fisher
Hal okay one of the things that struck
me as Patrick's reference to ordinary
Americans standing up for their country
and I think at times to not so ordinary
Americans we often wonder where the
people from OSS came from and where they
went and I had the privilege of doing a
documentary oral history with advice
Miller and I encourage anybody who knows
that to take the opportunity to say
hello to him but it was interesting to
me because II D by life's calling
is a poet and that's what he did before
he was made into a spy and all the
training and that's what he returned to
a very very distinguished American poet
so we came from all walks of life and I
think it's a good it's a great testimony
to the country and to the people who
came forward that that is true to last
things we will be doing on 15 March the
Ides of March a program on the
investigation that led to the capture
identification of aims in CIA there are
those who become turncoats unfortunately
and these are the two women who played a
role in that gene vertifight and sandy
Grimes that will be an evening program
here and so I wanted to mention that to
you in addition to the OSS program thank
you so much Patrick for being with us
today
we hope the book does very very well
you're helping to take an interesting
part of America's story and of course
one that the museum is dedicated to
please had with every one of my books
I'd like to invite the veterans in the
book to sign the books with me for
everybody all right Patrick would like
to invite those of you who are named in
the book right to sign the book with him
we will have books over here remember
your code name put that down you may
remember your code dealers because it's
been blown today as you know
and our book person Matt Arnold will be
running the show over there and stay
just as long as you do thank you so much
for coming today we really enjoyed it
ourselves
[Applause]